le match tant attendu de la 29e journée
de championnat de ligue 1 psg om aura
bien lieu demain au parc des princes
mais l'olympique de marseille a décidé
d'envoyer son équipe de réserve le club
estime que la sécurité n'est pas assurée
pour ses supporters une affaire qui
prend de l'ampleur du côté des ligues on
s'agace sérieusement christian réunis
mais nous en verrons une conférence de
presse convoquée à la hâte ce qu'il faut
bien appeler la sphère psg om continue
de faire des vagues
cet après-midi le patron du football
professionnel monte à son tour au
créneau le dirlo siffle la fin de la
récré les gens qui aiment le foot comme
vous comme moi en ont assez je dis bien
assez du triste spectacle qu'offre nou
2-2 nos principaux clubs
lorsqu'ils se rencontrent chaque fois on
a affaire aux mêmes dérapages aux mêmes
polémiques et aux mêmes incidents
ça suffit psg om la fiche aura lieu mais
sans les stars marseillaise c'est une
équipe de minots qui monte au parc car
pour l'om
la sécurité de ses supporters n'est plus
garantie vous mieux peut-être perdre
trois points que supporters soient
blessés ou qui se passe quoi que ce soit
nous qui porte ce maillot on les
soutient demain le parc des princes sera
sous haute surveillance
parisiens et marseillais ont travaillé
ensemble le dossier sécurité tout le
monde est d'accord depuis le 1er mars et
l'état français responsabilité pour
cette rencontre au parc des princes
ce ne sont pas moins de 1200 policiers
et gendarmes qui seront sur le terrain
pour assurer la sécurité avant pendant
et après le match
cet après midi l'entraîneur parisien a
montré son nouvel étendard au foot
citoyen lui livrer ses vérités celle du
terrain attention aux minots porter le
maillot de l'om
ça représente quelque chose pour chacun
de ces joueurs là il se sent ce sera aux
guerriers qui seront face à face à eux
donc il faudra vraiment donné le maximum
et moi je pars simple humidité je
respecte tous les adversaires quels
qu'ils soient
demain sur le terrain ils seront onze
parisien contre onze marseillais pour ce
qui devrait être un simple match de
football
j'espère que la raison l'emportera
j'espère c'est le théâtre du football
d'aujourd'hui
tout ça pour ça